minutes for those of you who are
familiar with my story I'll just start
out by saying I was a health education
volunteer in Cote d'Ivoire
otherwise known as Ivory Coast in West
Africa from 1998 to 2000 and my village
was a tiny very traditional Muslim
village in the northern half of the
country
it was an amazing life-changing
experience as I'm sure many of the
former Peace Corps volunteers in the
audience Linda let's say there's their
experience was - and when I returned
from my experience I realized that I was
actually compelled to write about it
that I had to write about it and so I
did and thus we have this book I'm going
to read a couple of different passages
tonight and the first one I'll start
with takes place in the training village
that I was in in the South called that
banking in the book it was about two
hours from Amazon and the reason I'm
going to read this part is because in
September 2002 about a year and a half
after I left the village or I guess two
and a half years after it left the
village the country kind of fell apart
and rebels from the north have taken
over the top half of the country and
it's a hard thing to see strangers still
because I was in a region of the country
where these rebels have come from and so
when I first heard their names I
actually thought hey those are my people
and I really sort of understood their
cause a little bit what has happened
though since September 2002 is that
they've laid seeds to their own people
and there are no angels and a lot of
victims from the conflicts but what is
striking is is the fact that in 1998 and
for volunteers who were there a few
years before then as well you could
sense the tension rising and so I don't
think it came as a giant surprise to any
of us that and that the events of 2002
happen as they did and this first little
bit is is sort of a fun piece but it
also gives you an idea of what people in
the South where I trained thought of
people in the north where I did my
service I should say also that I lived
with a host family with about 17
children of which probably six still
lived at home and the names you'll hear
in this little passage are all my
sisters and their respective children
facing me is the tiny bum of my favorite
child Ellen's daughter Eloise I sit in
the courtyard writing a letter only mama
number one is around and she's busy at
the fire boiling planten's hello is on
treacherous ground when her mother is
near Eloise traces around the courtyard
a dark sprite with a laugh like a
waterfall her hair twisted into long
strands and tied together at the end
looks like a fragile birdcage sitting
askew atop her head even after many
weeks she is still scared to death of me
yet she flirts
catching my eye and then scampering away
and giggling seriously she calls me miss
Sara as if she lived in Antebellum
Georgia and things now boldly I call
back miss alone and she thinks that's
pretty funny but she still can't decide
if I'm a big monster or remarkably pale
toy it's all right when their aunts and
grandmothers around to save her from the
white peril but today there's no safe
haven and she's nervous again she buries
her head in a wooden chair across from
me not quite sure she wants to sell me
her soul but too intrigued by her own
bravery to leave when I walked through
the village the sight of me sets naked
toddlers along the road to jumping and
chanting buffet buffet white white
Aloise and her mother walked back from
the market with me in the afternoon as
we passed jumping kids Eloise takes on a
funny swagger fast with her shoulders
swinging forward her chin is thrust in
the air as if to say hi she's my white
lady but as soon as Ellen ducks into a
friend's courtyard and instructs a load
to follow me home
confidence is lost she looks up at me
for one second and stubborn fear and
then Sprint's home elbows pumping her
yellowed lacy dress fluttering she is
off so fast she leads both shoes in the
dirt behind her I pick up one tiny
flip-flop and then the other completely
charmed this is beautiful my sister's
drift around me they comb each other's
hair and play with my fingers our square
of dim light under the Gerda Terrace
stays dry in the hushed straight rain
Eloise sleeps wildly next to mama number
one on a striped mat limbs flying
everywhere my sisters tell stories
compare their friend skills animated and
laughing they fold at the waist lean
into each other throw their heads back
clap their hands their voices rise and
fall with the rain soft static they're
flat strong nose is straight necks
smooth brown arms shine and the wet
night Thunder cracks violently but it's
like an accent to our joy we are
protected together Sophie has thrown her
arm around my shoulder I'm leaving soon
and none of us wants to think about it I
bring out my journal to read what I
wrote the first day I met them ha I was
so afraid of the sauce remember and you
tried to teach me to dance
hello rides and tosses maybe she's just
been faking sleep when I read what I
wrote about her her eyes flash up at me
she squiggles against her sleeping
grandmother every time she catches my
eye oh dear shouts soaking in a deep
voice console bah I'm back to school me
my god when you leave we will all fall
sick I asked for food too and peanut
sauce on my last night and nearly with
my plate Queen the Mamas and Ln watch
wide-eyed and then triumph washes across
their faces Papa has on his suit his
bowler hat and his glasses
we're playing one got one last game of
Ola one last game of cards
he has splurged tonight for my sake
bought a round of orange Fanta and a
kilo of popcorn
croisine is busy popping it over the
fire sprinkling it with salt and sweet
powdered milk and packing it into long
plastic bags for my trip north I'm ready
to be a health worker to try my hand at
changing behavior so my trainers say
infant mortality is high due to
dehydration malaria parasites
malnutrition unclean water sources poor
hygiene poor hygiene polio stubbornly
refuses to be eradicated outrace of
meningitis happened yearly in a
particularly hideous parasite called
guinea worm still trouble certain
regions preventive care is not a
priority most people wait till they get
sick before thinking about staying
healthy and traditional populations are
still skeptical with modern medicine my
destination is Memphis a tiny Muslim
village deep in the northern savanna
with one infirmary and one nurse I've
been told that many women in the north
are circumsized that there aren't many
maternity clinics there that women die
more often in childbirth
the north is poor less developed more
illiterate more conservative and more
isolated and AIDS
while less prevalent than in the south
is slowly infiltrating I've been trained
for this but it's daunting so he says
you know you won't be happy up north
where you're going it's really really
hot and how will you live all alone to
cook for you or do your laundry closing
looks up from her line of lumpy bags
you'll live in a hut you won't have any
light they don't even have electricity
up there you know
Sookie sucks 40 plus women air can't
even cook well the moon is shining
enlightening blasts all over the sky the
wind sisters sifts through the trees and
my lovely sisters laugh at the night
they're linked in a circle teaching
Emily's nine-month-old how to dance only
two days after she's learned to walk
she's picking it up fast bouncing up and
down with their knees a self-conscious
smile widening as she sees she's the
star
of the show Louise runs to me grab my
hands and thrusts her hips from side to
side
squealing at the great discovery that
I'm not that scary
her eyes twinkle up at me she spent nine
weeks
tricking across this courtyard to hide
for me and it's finally decided she
loves me too the week I'm leaving my
sisters stand smooth shoulders rising
out of Sirhan's black bodies fading into
the night before cheese bubbling into
music ln sways forward and thinks the
first bars of a song I've heard on the
radio and soon the four of us are
scratching out steps on the uneven
terrain dancing with a wind and
lightning so sweet this night the next
passage is from a chapter called dawn
and this is a slightly different
perspective on a an issue that sort of
goes hand-in-hand with Africa
unfortunately these days and I think
everyone in this chapter explains
themselves as it goes
Geneva comes to the village during
planting season she's got a giant bundle
on her head and a tiny baby on her back
that's all she has she can carry her
life for their hands-free she moves them
with a young family of autumn Ella
growth a man with a punch of all things
and he's not even 30 yet he is tall -
one of a handful of villagers over six
feet and the only one with more than
muscle on his bones
Adamo doesn't talk much but a smile is
easy and his movement slow he plays a
huge bass fella phone in the village
band the other musicians are wiry they
have to lean back to keep from pitching
over from the weight of their
instruments but atomized shoulders were
made to support when he plays he hunches
forward his arms move fast his face
doesn't flinch other my little girl has
three young lives to keep his courtyard
sweat and his pots bubbling they like to
sit on a plastic mat in the shade of a
mango tree and shelled peanuts to
they're braid each other's hair when I
pass by they're always there
a pocket of happy faces and supple
beckoning voices the third wife is a
[ __ ] with a charm smile and a foot
twisted inward the second is tall and
lied and laughs at everything
the first is Ollie Meza the only child
bearer of the three a LaMotta has
perfect teeth wouldn't doing sticks are
the main instruments of dental hygiene
but the villagers do all right
a few miles look like old graveyards
some teeth bend forward some backwards
some crumbled and chipped most others
have created spaces in their grins yet
the teeth that have made it are strong
enough for crunching chicken bones but
alimentive teeth are perfect when she
smiles they appear straight strong white
and bracketed by dimples we must have a
second in line the day I began weighing
babies she has come faithfully ever
since as if she's been waiting for some
way to prove herself I'm sure there's a
collection of French words that she
keeps bound up and dusty in the back of
her head but she never even lets one out
we've become friends over this year
through cobble together near death alone
the local language and gestures to her
two older children are in school
her youngest is a strapping baby girl
with a mouthful of my names and thinks I
am Satan
janab-i shows up in late June she's a
stranger in the village but no one seems
surprised when she appears the
population here is kinetic there are
always people leaving to work faraway
fields or care for elders and there are
always people coming just in relatives
who have hit rough time from the city
our son's come to live off parents when
janabat arrives our my third wife moves
her pile of surrounds to one side of her
house to share the space and Jennifer
finds a spot on the mat to shell peanuts
Jenna by impulse has come to stay her
husband died recently in the city
además interred dead husband's nephew
and also his closest male relatives so
according to tradition she becomes
Ottomans fourth wife this is life
insurance village style
the community doesn't let anyone fall
through the holes singing mom took all
his older brothers wives not in some
incestuous chauvinistic ownership Floyd
but out of duty best automatics Genna
Buhr as his wife he becomes her
breadwinner he safeguards for future
she's enveloped in family again when I
first meet Jenna mushy looks up at me
through her lashes and extends her hand
hesitantly she's nervous around this
white woman that old noxious inferiority
complex Bob's up again and it's up to me
to dissolve it so I run over to torment
alley Montez baby who can't figure out
whether to love me or be terrified by me
the child grins and then hollers loud i
chat with the crippled wife who's still
convinced that I have a husband hidden
away somewhere then I pick up a pestle
and help Ali Monsen pound corner pound
corn for a few minutes it works the
intimidation wears off Jennifer warms up
and brings her child over a month ago me
about the healthy baby contest she says
and not soft near docile oh I want to
enter like a song she holds up a bundle
with high cheekbones and a chiseled jaw
he's ecstatically perfect and tiny like
dollhouse furniture Robin's eggs and
it's not right for an infant to look
like this he should have chubby arms and
folds in his neck he should be laughing
or crying or spitting or something but
he just watches us serenely how old is
the Oscar for moves she hands them to me
he's not wrinkled up like malnourished
babies he's scrubbed clean and his skin
is smooth he's just unbelievably
miniature what does he eat I ask i
breastfeed him she says biting her lip
as if she might have answered wrong
kitchen gate I reassure her that's good
that's good and bewitched I can't stop
looking at this child with long lashes
and no flesh
he's angelic and so beautiful it's hard
not to cry and his eyes are bright
serious wise he gazes up at me with
vivid trust
unblinking and he makes no sound at all
Ali my friend Jenna bus show up at our
courses together
Ali wants a stubborn little giant jumps
all over her mother's back
she cranes to look over Ali much as
shoulder pylons her mother with playful
fists mother I don't
snuggle up to Jennifer's back and stay
still he watches everything those old
Wiseman eyes when I tell Jenna mother
since like that sounds a little small
she should probably come to a him every
week she nods eagerly and every market
day she's among the first in line
shoulders squared and smiling as she
unties live I got on from her back she
is so proud to be doing the right thing
just keep breastfeeding retailer don't
give him water or sugar or rice just
breast milk and the right vaccinations
and everything will be okay the lion and
Ali Martha's daughter's growth chart
soars along the top of the optimal range
she walks with confidence by now eating
rice and sauce and even fish Ali Mathur
assures me all about to decked her out
and bright frilly dresses from the
market leverage I don't mind wobbles
near the bottom for a while then it
flattens then it points downhill one
market day Jenna becomes before we
finish setting up the station
live-dot-com feels hot she says pulling
him around to her front his eyes shine
as if the moon were behind them cold
bags do nothing
trips to City Bay for medicine do
nothing his tiny body burns for days
little lab gets on is on fire a few
weeks later Jennifer Flags me down as
I'm heading back home from the market
the wives under the mango tree greet me
but their laughter is muted Latta got on
only way since Geneva
literally this means he doesn't exist
any more day today it's used to say he's
not well I stride right up to the baby
but I'm scared of what I might find
lava croissants eyelids are laced with
yellow crust his long eyelashes are
tangled my heart beats close it's
nothing more than pink eye I showed Jen
about how to put hot compresses on his
eyes and tell her not to let the other
kids touch him I tell her to go away in
a few days in a few days his eyes have
cleared but mysterious little bumps have
cropped up on his chest
bouton our button is the blanket term
that applies to any skin almond from
abscesses and boils to chickenpox and
minor rashes
they are constant and mostly benign
plague among children summer class by
allergic reactions others from insect
bites for contact with animals unless
the child complains of pain Luongo
remains unexplained and largely ignored
but lab accattone can't be ignored the
numbers don't fester they don't grow
this spread to his belly to his arms to
his legs let me go to Bhutan or sinister
as if something evil we're trying to get
out of that little body and I look at
him his delicate brow crumbles and his
eyes squeeze up to your slide across his
cheekbone past a little Bhutan by its
ear
he's not exactly crying the sound he
makes is a soft kneeling as if he's
already grown beyond babyish falling
beautiful letter that's on weeps and
then one day when I'm on my way to the
old man's boutique to pick up some sugar
Genevieve stops me in the middle of the
road her face looks fragile like her
sons she puts her hand on my wrist
laughing I thought well anyway she says
laughs that Don is dead looking in her
face and her hurt eyes all the puzzle
pieces that I've been fighting to keep
separate zoom into place of course aids
rears its head in the bunka Jennifer's
husband succumbed Jena bus baby
succumbed Geneva looking at me with
lambda tones eyes and her mouth pinched
is doomed and who owns the future it
turns my stomach the story has no end
watch the virus invade my village the
first domino has tipped and soon they'll
all be falling down Jenna bus story
isn't one of wonsan promiscuity or
prostitution or perla sness institute
the tale of tradition a sweet old
dependable tradition that keeps widows
and children from dereliction in poverty
but when
it seeps in the tradition goes bad if
item I had known to recognize his
uncle's killer as AIDS when he had kept
away from his new life no because
tradition over eyes pragmatism if he
didn't consummate the marriage he'd be
insulting his dead uncle and his new
wife trouble with the spirits weighs
heavier than gossamer rumors of modern
disease what will come of this courtyard
and we'll go first
Adama with his shoulders that can hold
up anything the third wife who limps
around the village at a clip and giggles
about my hidden husband smiling shining
a LaMotta when I come back in a few
years will there be no women laughing
under the mango tree what if these
children can run back from school and
clean uniforms and plastic shoes are
reduced to a handful of virgins and rags
without the means to continue their
education let alone eat rice with fish
other men will die in other towns and
cities their wives will appear in nan
bunka to become wives of their brothers
and nephews and no one will know that
their blood is infected so these shy
young women widows are poisoning the
village instead of sealing up the holes
in the community this tradition will
invite aids in to chew through families
and leave a lacy trail of orphans and
invalid
I think one of the beauties of serving
in West Africa is that there are some
pretty serious issues that are
underlying everyday life AIDS is
obviously one of them female
circumcision conflict there are so many
things that are underlying but day to
day life is that carries on in one of
the most joyous ways I've ever known and
I have to say I've never laughed so much
in those two years and I have never
laughed so much in my life as I left in
those two years at myself largely
because everyone else is laughing too
but but also just at life it was a very
carefree seeming way of life even though
they were grappling with these hard
issues so the last passage I will read
is interior and deals a little bit more
into everyday life and and what what I
did with some of the folks that were in
my village I would constantly have a
crew of children outside my my door and
it was a screen door in the beginning
they just stood there as if I was a TV
show and then we just watch me and I'll
eat and read and listen to the radio and
do other fascinating things like that
and they were just watches but toward
towards you know a couple months in they
they warmed up and I warmed up and we
became friends and so there are a few
kids who were just constantly by my side
and two of those are in learns and
they're in this next little chapter and
Hammar is a beautiful twelve-year-old
roughly twelve year old boy with I think
um hemophilia because his joints would
get very swollen and he wouldn't be able
to go to school every couple here every
couple months I used to tutor him in my
on the floor of my hut at night and the
other one is Musa who is what we would
call a bungee like a little rascal and
he was adorable but for mischievous
reasons and these are this is just a
little story about the three of us Tom
grasses swallow Omar and Musa a few feet
ahead of me we are winding through the
bush the three of us with my
Nik to get to my field Lamont has been
raving about them all week since school
got out in late July he's worked the
field daily he's wearing a blue baseball
cap and a blue t-shirt that shows the
faded outlines of beach equipment play
in the Sun it says and that's just what
we're doing he's all pride in simple as
as we cut through the glass grasses and
come upon the first row of corn stalks a
few days ago a mighty storm broke the
nearby dam and swelled the stream into a
brown see fields disappeared seven
meters under and just the tallest tree
tops floated on the surface the evidence
of the inundation is visible all over
Mars low-lying fields corn stalks life
scraggly and slain parts of the rice
fields are silty and flattened as if
someone had tried to brush them down
Kumar is on face his voice is high and
sweet as he points out the different
crops he snaps one of the down corn
plant strips the stem to its core and
gives it to me - it's sweet and spongy
like sugar cane birds might eat the corn
he says second his teeth they ruin it
that's why we think it's okay to shoot
them with our slingshots we think into
mud rest along the rice field to my dog
Nick bounds over peanut plants chasing
birds and field mice the boys run
through the rice stalks with their hands
out it's nice to look at is an ink ease
my village named Umar Umar faced with
Bob's just above the brilliant green
Spears loofah appears in dark slivers as
he moves there's clarity in the rice
field light gets bound up in there and
turns the whole world bright and
beautiful the sky is heart-stopping blue
who works the fields now I ask me on my
set for the fast grin what about your
mother mama says confusing her
grammatical gender as usual she comes
sometimes - and she's finished cooking
but Papa has to stay home because his
head hurts too much
we cut north in a big loop to find the
path home and come across a giant tree
cracked by the wind its trunk fallen
parallel to the pack spots of white
seeps from the bark boom our hops on and
scratches at the white stuff with this
twig it's like chewing gum he says
pronouncing it chingum since the French
haven't come up with a better word try
it and taste like nothing in squeeks of
it but it does feel like them I'm
chewing pure latex in the South rubber
trees are one of the most lucrative
crops
thanks to this pricey plastic that
dribbled out here in the North they
scrape it out with a smooth twigs and
use it as glue or gum pockets crammed
with Tomatoes arms full of corn cobs
chewing tiny bits of rubber we head back
to the village they'd like to draw they
say so I am throw my orange mat under
the mango tree and bring our scrap paper
and colored pencils Lamar has cracked
open their artistic horizons by drawing
instead of just square stick figures
playing soccer thinks he sees a pen a
chicken a hoe he and moves are both
concentrate hard on depending on
depicting my mango tree from underneath
it I'm cleaning house my little tail
them non-compostable trash fills only
every few weeks I usually dump it in a
shallow pit outside my courtyard and set
it on fire
routinely children come running no
matter how empty in the village seems
today Musa and Omar a fireside in a
flash they eye the prospects eagerly as
flames start to leg lick the edges of
envelopes and old rags then Musa swoops
in for a used-up scotch tape dispenser
an empty saline bottle may man how could
you he schools he fairs them away with a
righteous glance
within minutes little seeds have been
from every direction a hundred small
hands dodge flames to retrieve derelict
treasures scrolled to space too fuzzy
photographs empty match boxes they
retreat proudly with their booty Musa is
curled around his drawing when I come
back with my empty pail he gathers his
collection of loot and unloads it on my
table with an air of triumph look what
you and it's thrown out if it weren't
for me
please put these in my bag he says
referring to the ragged ziplock that
holds his crumpled pages of alphabet
practice and his pen he keeps all his
prized possessions at my house for
safeguarding from his older brothers
that's the clutter I was so happy to be
finished with finds its way back into my
house I'm such a sucker
Oh Myron Reis hesitantly to come back
after dinner for lessons like you used
to before my dog bit him he shows up in
nightfall with his sputtering of old
lantern I run into ring circus
alternately reading with Amara and
teaching basic words to Musa and Abu the
latter has been coming every other night
to practice writing their name their
names although who still hasn't figured
out what his last name is the home and
ask your mother I told him nightly he
nods eagerly each time and comes back
the next day smacking his forehead when
his hand forgot again Musa on the other
hand has decided his last name is you
even though his older brother goes by
Wat that uh whom I reached steadily but
he's just started fourth grade and his
new book is much harder than the last we
crawled through tonight's story his
voice like soft chimes his expression
serious the lamp light runs as their
faces their small hands cracked and dry
they're laughing and happy and I don't
really want them to go and the lessons
are done I put Kumar's corn on the flame
and to roast and toss them a magazine
it's a New Yorker not much in the way of
glossy photos and bright colors but
they're content with all those words
cramped together in the funny looking
scribbles what is that I asked pointing
to a cartoon they've seen the pictures
I've drawn for my health activities
they've seen the true-to-life drawings
in their textbooks but these sketches
baffle them into drawing just like you
and I draw I say see that's a woman and
that's a man and they're sitting at a
table talking their eyes go bright and
that precious sound of comprehension
comes from all three at once
huh they've got it but then they peered
closer the potato shaped heads with
dotted eyes and
Oh next and I really people who look
like that case not really I say they're
drawn that way to look funny to make
people laugh
that is no it Musa giggles and odd pages
ruffled by look at all the noses they
slam their fingers down on fat ones
pointy one ski-jump ones declaring fun
monofin on I plan on and each one nose
nose nose they come to a sketch of a
rocket what's this key seunggi an
airplane it's a special airplane that
can go above the clouds all the way up
to where the moon and the stars are
Melissa's up straighter says hi blue my
eyes are wide and incredulous he studies
the picture again and then looks up at
me
his voice wilts on the nut soft night
air he asks me jeez when I go up there
did they see good
[Applause]
so if anyone has any questions and happy
answer there's one over here Sarah can
you tell me about your most memorable
memorable experience serving as Peace
Corps volunteers
yeah there were a line of them but one
of the most memorable ones and I don't
want to give away any stories but I'm
going to is that when I had the healthy
baby scientist that I mentioned in that
chapter that I read about aids was one
that we did for six months and we had
all these women who would come to these
courses and they would weigh their
children and they would vaccinate but
the most important thing with the
courses because these were women who had
never been to school had never been
asked to even read a drawing let alone a
word and so we gave them a course every
month and we tried to get them to
regurgitate what we would what we had
said at the end of each course and then
we sort of held our breath and when it
came to the final ceremony we practiced
with a woman about a couple hours before
the ceremony because we wanted them to
deliver sort of summaries of what we had
said during these courses and you know
the first course was six months back so
we said this is what we would like you
to do and now who remembers anything
from the course six months back and this
is in a village where the word today I'm
sorry where the word yesterday is the
same as the word tomorrow so the whole
idea of time you know it's sort of
negligible so six months back nutrition
course there's a big silence and my
health workers and I just sat there
thinking this is the biggest test so now
you know maybe maybe they got nothing
and then they just started talking and
they threw out facts lesson right all of
the women they just started oh yeah and
we remember that yeast you know start
weaning at this age and colostrum is
important even though it doesn't look
like milk and and they just started
spitting out
and it was the most amazing moment just
because I realized that our work six
months ago or worked five four three two
you know one months ago had worked they
had remembered it they wanted to know
and they and they had retained it and I
was so proud of them and it was it was
this wonderful sign that they were they
had so much potential and they had lived
up to it so it's a really great moment
joy thank you for your writing I really
enjoyed it out with the Peace Corps
volunteer in Togo and the descriptions
are so vivid and beautiful just brought
back a lot of memories my question is
about the writing process you had
mentioned that you kept a journal and
I'm curious at what point did you decide
you were going to write a book and did
you have any formal experience writing
and how did you go about it when you
came back well there are a lot of
questions wrapped up in myself so I'll
start out with them did I have any
experience and the answer ISM I would
like to write as a history major and
that meant I wrote a lot I wrote for my
college newspaper I wrote tortured
poetry in high school but other than
that I'd never written for another
audience I don't think that my newspaper
experience in school while it was
worthwhile you know that didn't really
prepare me for this I really like to
write and I had gotten somewhat a good
feedback about my writing so I wrote
letters best back home all the time and
as you mentioned kept a journal very
very faithfully I think if you talk to
people who started training with me back
in 1998 they would say I mentioned
writing a book and it could be true but
I actually once I got to my village it
became so much bigger than anything I
would do after Peace Corps what was
important was here and now and figuring
out what was going on and how I could
communicate and how I could manage to
get through this awful looking meal but
of course I miss now
but so it became a lot more writing
because I had to write because there's
no one else who thought this was quite
as exotic as I did you know it was
everyday life to villagers and for me it
was an amazing moment you know every
every five minutes and so I really felt
like I had to write so I wrote in my
journal very faithfully for those two
years and then at the end I traveled to
East Africa
I'm trying enjoyed a lot and no offense
to anyone it's meant that East Africa it
really made me miss West Africa because
I had understood the rhythms there so
much better and East Africa was
different territory so I didn't fit in
as well and I couldn't adjust as well
and it just made me realize that I had
all these stories to tell and my fingers
were kind of jumping with them I
actually had to come back and write them
so I decided when I was traveling in
East Africa that I would for certain
come back and write and I didn't know if
there was going to be a book at the time
I just knew that I needed to write it
and in the end I finished the manuscript
and was pretty much that is satisfied
with it before I tried to shop it out to
publishers in question
thank you for sharing a piece of your
life with us I really appreciate that
I'm curious has this book been
translated into French and when will be
translated because I think it's a
wonderful story to share with the
communities in cookie cool yeah I really
hope to do so the trans we are still
working on and especially a French
translation we haven't had any bites yet
but I'm hoping I've had actually a valid
places it's had a pretty strong
leadership in Algeria
my parents happened to be living there
and my father happens to farm it out to
every single person to come to play but
because of that we've had a lot of
French speakers who read it and said
this needs to be in French so that
French people and Franklin Africans can
read it and I completely agree and I
have one woman who's agreed to translate
it but I'm just nervous about roping her
into translating it's in fact we should
we can sell the rights to it so I would
love to see it translated into French
and I think regardless of whether or not
it is translated I need to go back to
the village to present them with this
book they know I've written the book and
in fact my nurse CD Bay in the book
whose name is not actually see anybody
wrote me an email recently and he he
needed some help he needed a little bit
of financial help and so he wrote saying
sube needs your help
kind of funny since that's that's the
name I gave him and not interesting but
so you know they're on board and they
know that I've written this book I'm not
sure that they know exactly what it
means to have a book out about them I
think they were not a reading society at
all I think I was the only one who ever
picked up a book for for pleasure in the
village except my nurse who read the
Quran so I need to go back and present
it to them as a daughter of the village
to to take it to the Chiefs and let them
know I've done it and hopefully it'll be
in French by that time
I would like to make a comment instead
of a question I'm from The Advocate and
I'm from adopting the South also and I
work in the field I am from the field of
public health and this is one of the the
right time or occasion I can see
somebody from the public health field
writing a book about health issue excess
in the world but with beauty that is
some other people forget when very
direct about population like in Africa
so that is something very I was able to
ask the question how will you share that
Duty that should the masterpiece you
created to the population in advocate of
fertility
I really hope so and I want to go back
because as I said before I feel not only
do I need to present us this to the
village but I really feel obligated to
help the village as much as I can and to
help kochevar how can I share it with
them I'm not sure actually an
interesting stories while I was in
Algeria recently visiting my parents I
met any boring and diplomat and he
actually came from a village left foot
Boca I mentioned about 22 kilometers
away from my village and his wife came
from one of the field settlements of my
village and today both Fred the book
it's not just a good they their English
was only so-so you know so they read the
book as much as they could and their
response to it was really amazing I mean
they they were very touched that I'd
love their community enough to write
about it but regardless of all of that
and I hope that they understand some of
the issues that I wrote about and I hope
you know that they came across and sort
of literary English to people who don't
speak English that that well and I
really do hope that it it is translated
into French so that it Orient's can read
it but until then you know
I don't know I had this vision of me
going back to the village and sort of
going through chapter by chapter and
turning it into a good village well a
friend fever but I don't know if that's
going to happen but I think that is
mented pointment welcome any question I
was just wondering two years and in such
a different environment is a long time
what was the transition like coming back
well I kind of cheated because I went to
Montana and lived in a house by myself
for three months right after I got back
so which was a little bit difficult in
itself but it's it's definitely not easy
for a lot of different reasons and you
tend to being in a place like that
really makes you view your own country
in a different light and also hearing
what you've ourian's had to say about
our country made me to you our country
in a different light things like for
instance the Monica Lewinsky scandal was
happening while I was there and for
those of you have read the book you'll
remember that my villagers all thought
it was pretty ridiculous that you know a
president was getting called to task for
for cheating on his wife the justices
meant the right of a president and you
know I would try to say I would say no
it's not about that it's about the
sanctity line and you know people are up
in arms about that and and they said
yeah is that I've normal so that was
very interesting that just to see my
country and their perspective but coming
back was was definitely difficult I had
done it many times before because I'm a
foreign service brat so I lived many
years of my youth overseas and I had
already had that grocery store moment
when you get to the cereal aisle and
freak out but
and but it said it did definitely hit me
in a lot of different ways made it
easier than I was that I was in Montana
and only saw other people once a week
for three months and but it's very
difficult I think I'm just writing this
- to a woman who figured out my work
email address and wrote me saying that
she read the book and she was
considering doing Peace Corps and and I
while writing Bakshi she had the same
question and while writing back to her I
sort of came up with this idea that how
you react
sometimes determines what you do later
on what you do with the next couple
years you know some people I can come
back and realize I do not want to be
here and so they go right back out as
fast as possible and other people come
back and realize well this these two
years were really important and really
formative but I've had them and I'm
going to use them in this way back home
and so I think they're extremely
important and I think that the suffering
or the the struggle that people go
through in those two years in this those
moments after you come back and usually
it lasts at least a year I think it's
worthwhile definitely there another
question
oh yeah how how will you decide how will
you decide I think you told me
previously that you wanted both to write
and to do more health care Peace Corps
kinds of work how will you decide what
your next project will be or you in that
stage yet where you're you're thinking
ahead yeah I am actually I'm I'm going
to depend on the line of different
things um but when I was giving away too
much I have a plan in the works to move
abroad and to keep moving every couple
of years and I think through that I'll
be able to determine what I write about
or at least where I'll be when I'm
writing about it and I really do want to
try I think one of the things that I've
been so struck by with with this book is
that audiences all over the states have
really responded to it at least to my
face they have but I think it's
interesting because Peace Corps and any
any other agency that's worried about
your readjustment will always tell you
you know go when you go back to the
States
don't expect anyone to really be
interested and you know you might get
two questions out of out of your best
listener but they'll tune out after a
little while but the truth is that with
this book I think I realized that it's
not that people aren't interested in so
that they don't know how to ask the
questions about a place that they're so
familiar with and so with this book they
found that it gives them enough of a
platform to start asking questions and I
remember being out in Montana with
ranchers who had never left the country
and I gave them one little story to read
from the manuscript and and all of a
sudden it just was out of control we
talked for three hours standing up next
to a horse
and they were so interested in so many
questions and so I think I really want
to not only try to incorporate good work
and writing but also to try to bring a
conflict or other cultures cultures in
conflict or just other cultures that are
not very well known to an American
audience because I think what's the most
important in the end is building
tolerance and understanding man in
question couple men there in light of
the current conflict going on Cote
d'Ivoire Nabby what do you see is the
best way for foreigners to help if any
and what do you think is the best hope
for the future well um if I can promote
our little nonprofit we have a group
called Friends of Cote d'Ivoire and
we're trying to raise money to send a
shipment of medical supplies over there
it's really difficult because who do you
decide to help and how can you make sure
that your help is actually even get to
the people and not get lost in the
bureaucracy and the reason we chose this
group is that they take the shipment and
they take it straight there and we know
exactly what it is that is going and we
know where it's going to go and so that
is one way of doing it
friends of Cote d'Ivoire or get anyone's
interested and what is the second part
of your question what do you think is
the best hopeful future yes okay native
Cote d'Ivoire
well I'm sure a foreign friend can help
me answer this one but um it's that it's
a really difficult situation I think
right now the politicians the last I
heard I think last week the news was
that the politicians are trying to come
back to the Peace Accords and there were
these Peace Accords that were decided in
France in January 2003 and then they
were kind of forgotten and the whole
complained the whole time since then has
been the rebels have been saying we want
you to abide by the peace agreements
that the
government forces have been saying we
want you to disarm and neither of them
doing or so it's a basically a point of
stagnation right now but they have
brought in all of these West African
leaders echo us and they have they're
trying to mediate and so that's a
positive sign definitely and the rebel
leaders have now rejoined the government
and they are hopefully working towards
getting back to that peace agreement but
it's um I don't know I think you I think
it's going to be harder than just
political and treaties I think it's it's
a question of having the people of the
country regain faith and the other
people there because right now I think
it's just so factionalized and and
there's there's a lot of hatred towards
the people who you aren't you know in
the south and in the north and it's not
I don't think a religious conflict so
much as geopolitical one religion plays
into it a little bit but not so much it
just so happens if some North is mostly
Muslim and the South is mostly Christian
but in the end I think it's a lot bigger
than that it's most it's a its power and
and population and ethnicity and
everything else so it's scary and I want
it together a lot and I think the first
step is definitely going to be to have
some sort of political reconciliation
but I I'm not sure you know where it's
going to go from from there so yeah one
more question I was in the Peace Court
and Ghana near the coast he was in the
south so I understand the north/south
and differences one of the things I
think about often as our population is
aging is the role of the elderly in the
small village and how vital a role they
played can you talk a little bit about
that yeah and they were just extremely
well respected and the villages and I
only really speak for my own village
because that's the one I knew best but
it had a very well-established political
system in itself and the chief was sort
of like our dictator present
and whatever he was and then the elders
were his his I guess it was more like an
oligarchy because they were quite
powerful too and they were the judges of
the village and that to me was just
representative of how the culture viewed
elders overall and that was that they
really respected them even to the point
of a five-year-old kid respecting
six-year-old friend and you know doing
going out of his way to do something for
6-year old friend it really made the
society work extremely well and and it's
something that I think it's some it's
something that our culture could could
use as well I think because it really
wasn't overriding sense of the dignity
and the respect to these people's
deserved the entire community was ready
to give it to them so yeah I remember
well having going into little villages
out in the fields and having everyone
lead me directly to the woman who was
100 years old and of course they never
wrote down the birthdays especially 100
years ago so who knows how what she was
really but anybody who was really
wrinkled up and really small and
couldn't walk was definitely 100 and and
she was kind of museum piece of the
whole village to them
so anyway well thank you very much for
coming and a good
nine Hills to Nando and cop two years in
the heart of an African village is
published by Picador visit